Ben Shapiro has bought receipts. He's
bought receipts that the Mossad Island
Gizlain Maxwell, Robert Maxwell,
Epstein, these are not Mosad agents.
They've got nothing to do with Israel.
She's about to get exposed by Ben
Shapiro.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhana wa
tala. So make it count, brothers and
sisters, and donate towards this message
inshallah. a new project that's only
£500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1, £10, £100,
£1,000, that's going to be something you
will never regret on your Makyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds on your
Makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video
brothers and sisters in defense. Okay,
so here's a video of Kenneth Owens um
you know being exposed being exposed by
Ben Shapiro. Ben Shapiro has bought
receipts. He's brought receipts that the
Mossad Island, Gizlane, Maxwell, Robert
Maxwell, Epstein, these are not Mossad
agents. They've got nothing to do with
Israel. She's about to get exposed by
Ben Shapiro. Let's watch it inshallah
for ourself and let's see what evidences
and receipts Ben Shapiro has for us.
Let's see. She went out there and
claimed there were tens of thousands of
hours of tape. There are, by the way,
but they are child pornography. The
reason the FBI is not releasing them is
because those tapes do not include
underage people with third parties on
Epstein Island. That is not what the
tapes are. I also have sources in the
federal government who are covering this
stuff and have seen the documents. Okay,
those tapes are just child porn. That's
all. That's what they are. That's why
the FBI is not releasing them. Okay, as
far as the Epstein list, what I have
been told by my sources is that the
there is no Epstein list. that basically
there's a black book of Jeffrey Epstein
contacts and the vast majority of those
contacts are already out there publicly.
That's why you know names like Prince
Andrew or Alan Dersowitz or some of the
names that have been mentioned here
those contacts there is no evidence
according to the DOJ and the FBI and
again that's public. There's no evidence
that any of those third parties were
having girls trafficked to them and that
is not evidence that was made clear
certainly to the DOJ or the FBI. Here is
Tucker then asserting that it was
actually Assad. Again, without evidence
that not not a shock. Of course, this is
where Tucker was going. This has become
the hot speculation on the internet is
without evidence. You say that MSAD was
running Jeffrey Epstein. When I say
without evidence, I mean without
evidence. There you go, guys. There is
no evidence. Okay, there there's zero
evidence. And he's going to bring the
count evidence to why it was not an
island uh run by Mossad to blackmail the
elite to control them. Navali Bennett,
the former Israeli prime minister, said,
quote,
"As a former Israeli prime minister,
with the MSAD having reported directly
to me, I say to you with 100% certainty,
the accusation that Jeffrey Epste
somehow worked for Israel or the MSAD
running a blackmail ring is
categorically and totally false. This
accusation is a lie being pedled by
prominent online personalities such as
Tucker Carlson, pretending they know
things they don't. And in fact, I
followed up with the former prime
minister Natali Bennett. And what he
told me is that MSAD has not been active
in the United States since the or
against the United States since the
Jonathan Pard scandal of 1987 when a US
Army contractor, he's actually working
for the Navy re revealed classified
information to the Israeli government.
He was prosecuted by the United States
government and ended up in prison.
>> I didn't watch this. This is hilarious.
>> And so Israel since then has not spied
on the United States with MSAD.
>> I mean, you can't make this up. So he's
got connections to the Israelis, okay,
the government, etc. Ben Nef, whatever
that is, the scumbag may Allah destroy
him. So he's come out, can you imagine
the one who was running, you know, he
was running the country at one point who
was the president of Israel. Okay. Um
he's come out and said, "No, no, no, no.
Yeah, I can 100% tell you guys it was
not us and we're going to say yes." It's
like it's like catching someone in the
act or whatever it is for that matter
and then he's Oh, no, no, no. I I've got
evidence. What's the evidence? It wasn't
me. You know, that's what Shi said, you
know, in the song. It wasn't me. you
know he's you know it's a haram track.
Okay. You know, even Shag music was
saying, you know, caught me here, it
wasn't me. Caught me there. It wasn't
me. Wow. What an evidence. What what's a
fantastic evidence coming from Ben
Shapiro? Nobody saw. And Ben, whatever
his name is, the dirt bag saying 100% we
wasn't working there. And that's what
Candace almost. Look what she had to
say.
Okay guys, well, there you have it. It's
just
I don't know how he does it with a
straight face. It's like
well anyway guys there's millions of
females but don't even like it's like
massage hasn't been doing nothing. I
know it seems weird because BB's like
always here or whatever and we seem to
be doing their everywhere but the MSAD
just like said in night they were like
I'm a chill I'm a chill and they haven't
done a single thing here at all. I know
it might look that way. Miriam Mel said
she doesn't even know their name. She
doesn't know who they are actually. uh
she's doing her thing and she's giving
Trump $200 million but it ain't got
nothing to do with the facade. So I just
wanted to bring you that stunning report
um from Ben Shapiro.
>> And this is what I say the Israelis
these Zionists their biggest weakness
strength is as well also their how in
bold they are how how how they think
that subhan Allah that they can their
confidence and it's also their biggest
weakness and Allah subhanaa tala will
expose them. They thought they can just
go do what they like and now Allah is
exposing them to the entire dunya to the
entire world who is behind all this
evil. the laughing Israelis Zionists
when the 9/11 attacks happened when they
attacked the USS Liberty JFK's
assassination Charlie Kirk disappearing
all of a sudden and the Pedo Islands as
you can see which is a direct connection
in brother and sisters and cancel look
at this look at with a straight face
that you think that people are going to
believe you and what's your evidence
someone that you know in the Israeli
government saying no we were not
involved wow bravo fantastic fantastic
desperate times call for desperate
measure brother and sisters inshallah
that's all I want to say and show you
guys that Ben Shapiro and the rest are
finished. The whole world has woken up
to the reality and there's going to be a
change in Israel knows that their time
is up and that's all I want to bring to
your attention guys in brother and
sisters this time may Allah carry on
exposing them and a big big up to
Candace Owens for being a true Christian
and standing by her values
unlike the coward Tristan Tate who's
supposed to be a Christian who got
exposed. Goodbye. Everything you own
from your clothes to your car to your
wife or your husband is going to forget
you and move on and be replaced the
moment you die. That's why Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000. And believe me if every single
one of us give £1,10
£1,000 that's going to be something you
will never regret on your makyama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. But your deeds and your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.